if you haven't started last of us just
watch the first three episodes that's
awesome that's the only episode yeah
yeah yeah
you can't just tell him to watch the
whole thing watch everything
all in one night
um great show
this third episode and I'm gonna do this
thing which is gonna kind of ruin the
experience for people who haven't seen
it just yet uh not only where I spoil it
but I like set an expectation really
high so I apologize but I think it was
one of the best single episodes of
television in history
you said that in the text and I was
ready to be let down but it was actually
[__] beautiful
like beautiful it was yeah from the text
Last of Us episode was one of the
greatest episodes of Television I've
ever seen in my life my life I mean it
was [__] and the thing is
I thought it was about to be some woke
[__] right because the episode
surrounds this character these
characters Bill and Frank bill is like a
uh what are they called what's that I
call them a bottom yeah
I think Bill's the top yeah really did
you see the episode did you see the
episode okay so it's like Frank is the
one that comes over he's a little bit
more classically gay if you will okay
you know but who knows you never know
how it gets down he's like yo go go take
a shower
but uh but but basically what happens is
um he's uh he called himself a Dooms
he's like a doomsday prepper doomsday
prep Resort yeah yeah yeah yeah so like
one of the cool things about the show is
that it doesn't just focus on like here
these guys trying to get away from
zombies it's like what happens to the
world that's the most interesting thing
to me about like post-apocalyptic [__]
I'm like I want to know what human
beings really care about and also like
what we do when there's no rules what
rules do we recreate what lives do we
live and like it follows this couple
they weren't initially a couple but um
this dude who was a Doomsday prepper so
like what happens to the Preppers when
there's apocalypse and the dude prepped
and he wasn't going to leave his home
and he wasn't going to go to a
quarantine Zone get out when they try to
take everybody to the quarantine Zone he
had a Bunker full of [__] guns and
they go through a cool scene where he
like comes up sees the town is empty
goes and [__] steals like a generator
from the power and then the music
changes and he's like having a time of
his life he's going to Home Depot
getting all the [__] that he needs to do
he's turning the gas back on like it's
like what the prepper would do finally
it's his time that's what Preppers think
they would do they would think most
Peppers right like they have all this
[__] mashed potatoes that are
powdered and they go to like get sent to
a camp immediately yeah like all those
people I got a bunch of guns sitting in
their basement they're like Cece
I told you yeah so like uh and then
basically he creates this kind of like
you know Fortress in his town and
whatever this guy comes and uh you the
guy ends up seeing that the prepper is
actually gay he doesn't come across gays
at all he's the parks and rec guy yeah
Ron Swanson or whatever like that is gay
yeah and like it's a lot of bearded
kissing you prefer a beard or no beard I
love love
yeah
anyway nobody wants to see that gay [__]
look
and but and I thought it was going to be
that I thought they were like
shoehorning this this like Progressive
story into this HBO show and I'm like
okay there was some execs at HBO and
they're like oh we need to make sure
yeah and then it ends up becoming like
the coolest love story that I've ever
seen on TV and it was just like it was
like how these people survive how do
they Thrive together and then things
happen in the episode that like you
don't even consider it's like when the
dude gets I guess what the version of Ms
is yeah it's like yeah that's gonna
happen and there's no medicine and
there's nobody that you're gonna go to
like you're just stuck in that world you
better hope you got a [__] wheelchair
yeah you know and like it was just this
beautiful moment and then uh the ending
the ending of their relationship was
awesome yeah and uh but the coolest part
was the note that he leaves to Joel all
right guys we're gonna take a break for
a second because you got 24 hours
time is ticking you have 24 hours to go
to gamersups.gg and get the best [__]
powdered energy drink in the flagrant
Universe for free they're giving out
free samples for 20 [__] four hours
you need to go do that right now yes
it's the best it's the keto friendly
zero sugar organic caffeine no fillers
six of the body's most crucial vitamins
and minerals the electrolytes but who
cares you don't care about that you want
to stay up you want to stay focused you
want to stay locked in and gamer Subs
has got your back and you know what else
they got it for free flagrant make sure
you use that promo code flagrant at
gamersupps.gg oh you live International
oh they're gonna kill you with the
shipping international shipping is free
too you got no excuses you're welcome
you got no excuses you're welcome go now
24 hours it's actually less than that
from the beginning of this ad it's even
less time is ticking but you know where
you're going to make it up you staying
all night blasting through video games
whatever the [__] you need to do with
that gamer Subs go get it right now
promo code flagrant let's get back to
the show he leaves this note to Joel
because he knows Joel's gonna eventually
find him and he's basically like I
didn't even like you you know but like I
respected you and I know that you end up
finding this and uh you know like I when
the world burned and everybody died I
was happy because I hated the world and
then I found Frank yeah and he gave me
purpose and my purpose was to protected
he says that to him before he died
before they you know however yeah he
says you were my purpose yeah and that I
was like [__] that's beautiful and but
he goes my purpose was to protect
protect him and he goes and he's like
and that's what guys like me and you I
gotta I gotta [__] get it right
because the line was fantastic so I want
to make sure I get it exactly so smart
at HBO they checked
I was hoping the guy would live because
he could be [__] useful to help them
on their like Mission well that's kind
of what happens as opposed to in the in
the video game yeah they do it like that
but uh you should be grateful dude you
guys are gonna make it to the end of
movies now I mean they got to put us in
the this one first well yeah you know if
you make it yeah if you make it well
they kind of did and she died actually
very first so okay so the stereotype
still holds yeah yeah yeah as long as
there's order in the universe as long as
y'all are dying first in the movies they
made the show about the black girl for
20 minutes and then killed her [__]
grease yeah damn it [__] so here's a
quote it goes um there was one person
worth saving and that's what I did I
saved him and protected him he goes
That's why men like you and me are here
we have a job to do and God help the
[__] that get in our way and it
was like
is that when you started crying bro hell
yeah I watched that re-watched that [__]
seven times seven I loved that [__] I
just love that idea like
that's great I love it I was like yeah
that's what you tell people before they
storm the beaches of normally you know
what I mean like anything or the capital
yeah before storming yeah before storm
before there's a storming happening
stops yeah yeah but it's like yeah it
was just I was such a great episode and
to go from being annoyed
that I thought that they were trying to
like project this like a goofy you know
Progressive agenda goofy or not an
agenda I don't want to project it on me
I don't want you to force your agenda on
me whatever it is I literally have a
text so I was sending to uh uh some
buddies and the first thing is like why
am I watching you know Ron Swanson get
his colon blasted HBO Jordan Peterson
wait a minute this is kind of cool and
the next one is just like now I'm crying
at this [__] like I just melted on it I
almost texted you why am I watching
brokeback apocalypse
but I gave it a chance and it ended up
being funny but that is what you should
do with gay stories right like it's not
about them being gay it's about yeah
it's about their relationship and what
that means for the world yeah that's how
you that's how you make it relatable
that's how you normalize it they go
through the same things that you would
go through and how you would feel if
somebody was you know gonna die like
what would you want to do if that
purpose the purpose for you being alive
is now going to go away yeah you're
gonna die essentially too and uh yeah it
was [__] amazing man they killed that
[__] yeah really yeah yeah I don't know
I was told this that you have to watch
the first three episodes by somebody who
was like you know represents some guys
that are on it and he was like you just
get through the first three and then
you'll see what this show can be and the
cool thing about it is
Joel's character
now begins essentially yes so as one
character ends his begins like your job
is to protect that girl right that's
what you do you're a protector
[__] that's why you have this
skill set you did that [__] with that
girl Tess you did it with your daughter
it's like that is why you're alive and
now he gets to live again yeah and now
you know his purpose and then everything
else he does through the rest of the
series you're like oh they don't know
why he's doing that but we all know why
he's doing that yeah yeah it's gonna be
fine and I'm back in well I wasn't out
but I'm back anymore because they
deviated from the video game yeah I was
like okay now I don't know everything
that's gonna happen now exactly because
we don't know what other times they're
gonna DVD
and I like the fact that they're going
like back and forth in time because I
want to know how people react in the
first few years of this [__] yeah like
how you ended up building up a
quarantine Zone what were the
difficulties of building up the court
who decides who's in control this clip
has been brought to you by our patreon
which is patreon.com flagrant join the
[__] Army right now